Alaska is home to one of the world's
densest populations of bears and one
just showed up at nd passages remote
homestead this is Gary for me because
all bears are dangerous quite frankly
they're intelligent they're predatory
and when they come out of hibernation
they're hungry like you go early in the
springtime up here bears are our early
meat it's the first fresh meat that we
see after a long winter it's in the yard
here so he's going to be dinner tonight
seem in the woods sir I hear in the
woods
if Andy doesn't get the bear now it
could return and take him by surprise
again
bad day for the bear good day for me the
sparrow didn't back down he kept coming
even when I yelled at him he wasn't
afraid of me at all good girl good girl
that's what I want you to do we smell
them dad you gotta let me know my hand
looking at us hide looking at his teeth
he looks like a really healthy bear so
this should be some really good eating
it's really unusual for me to see bears
this time of the year I think that's why
I had my guards down a little bit on
this there are a lot of wild animals up
here and you're on their turf a lot of
times and so you got to be careful
all right now see if we can't get this
guy drug in start getting them butchered
up here